and the Kansas City Chiefs have won
Super Bowl 57.
all eyes were on Patrick Mahomes after
the Kansas City Chiefs quarterback LED
his team to victory at the Super Bowl
right now Patrick Mahomes is like my
favorite quarterback in the NFL
meanwhile his younger brother Jackson
offered a different POV of the big game
The influencer Who boasts more than a
million Tick Tock followers took fans
inside the family's box seats
he sat with Patrick's wife Brittany and
their almost two-year-old daughter
Sterling Skye
Jackson sang along to Rihanna's halftime
show
[Applause]
but what got the big action from fans
Jackson's selfies snapped inside a
stadium bathroom
[Applause]
thankfully Jackson made it back to his
seat in time to document big bro's big
moment
if social media is any indicator the
Mahomes brothers are pretty close even
during times of controversy obviously
it's something that we don't want to
necessarily do Patrick coming to
Jackson's defense in 2021 after he was
filmed dumping water on a Ravens van
after the Baltimore team beat the Chiefs
there was being said to him and Brittany
that that you don't see kind of on the
clip
um but I mean he's been good at it at
not trying to respond to that stuff he
takes a lot and he's usually pretty good
at it and he'll learn from it and just
try to stay away from those people as
best he can the 22 year old's massive
following includes a number of critics
who don't hold back their thoughts on
Jackson's content the latest instance
his post Super Bowl lip sync to Miguel's
sure thing on the field moments after
the Chiefs took home the trophy
[Music]
but over on the NFL's Tick Tock they
captured a sweet fam only moment Patrick
embracing his and Jackson's dad Jackson
getting the footage from a different
angle clearly nothing but a whole lot of
Brotherly Love here
[Music]